it is a pleasure to welcome back to the
program Sean Carroll who is a
theoretical physicist at Caltech host of
the podcast mindscape and also author of
the forthcoming book something deeply
hidden which is out in September maybe
we start there Sean I mean what is it
with this idea of something being hidden
is very interesting when we talk about
your work what is it that you allude to
there as being hidden from us well it's
a quote from Einstein actually and the
book is about quantum mechanics and the
fact that for the whole 20th century
physicists kind of punted the attempt to
truly understand what was going on in
quantum mechanics so something deeply
hidden refers to Einstein's conviction
which I share that there's something
going on behind the operation of the
natural world when we talk about quantum
mechanics we've often not really pressed
our best theoretical theories on what is
happening we make a quantum measurement
I think it's time to actually face this
problem head-on why would it be that we
don't press as much as we might in that
area well it's hard you know the quantum
mechanics is mysterious mostly because
it seems to imply that what truly exists
the true nature of physical reality is
different from what we see when we look
at it right there's a difference between
measurement outcomes and physical
reality and that's something that no
other physical theory has ever featured
so way back in the 1920s and 30s
physicists settled on a coping mechanism
which they called the Copenhagen
interpretation which asked us to sort of
not ask too carefully what happens when
you make a quantum measurement and I
think that we can do better than that by
now how do you explain to laypeople not
only in the simplest possible terms what
what quantum mechanics is but also why
it even matters because I think
sometimes there's a contingent that when
faced with something as complicated as
quantum mechanics it can be easy to say
if I don't even understand why that
matters to me or why that matters to
human life I'm not even gonna think
about it too much like why is this stuff
important
yeah quantum mechanics is mysterious
because
were useful like seeing particles right
we say that there's a particle it has a
position it has a velocity and quantum
mechanics says that's not what is really
happening particles have a wavefunction
and you can observe their position you
can observe their velocity but that's
not what is really going on and
nevertheless quantum mechanics is at the
center of all of modern physics it is
the most important theory we have and it
is incredibly important to understand
things like atoms electricity
transistors lasers all of modern
technology is based on quantum mechanics
in one way or another to me the most
vivid fact about quantum mechanics is
that without it matter would be
completely unstable electrons would not
stay orbiting the nuclei of atoms the
chair you're sitting on would not be
solid it would all just collapse into a
black hole in a tiny fraction of a
second so quantum mechanics is kind of
really important to how we understand
the universe right now so to play
pseudo-intellectual devil's advocate is
it important to understand those things
for the layperson
as long as they work you know you don't
understand anything really to get
through life except you know how to eat
and how to sleep and so forth but I
think that what makes us human is
something very different right I think
that human beings like to do more than
simply survive of course you can get
through your daily life as long as your
daily life is not that of being a
physicist without knowing that much
about quantum mechanics but it is the
best theory we have of the fundamental
nature of reality and it is
understandable so if you give in to the
human impulse to be curious to
understand the world around us then
understanding quantum mechanics should
be very high on your list of priorities
yeah very very well set can you talk a
little bit about some of the ways in
which a better understanding of quantum
mechanics could be a game-changer
over the next I mean whatever timeline
you you think is relevant I mean whether
it's 20 years or 50 years or a hundred
years in what ways will a better
understanding of quantum mechanics
change the way in which humans interact
with the world around us in our
environment well I think there's two big
waves it's you know it's very
interesting to imagine that we've been
using quantum mechanics for 90 years or
so
and it's our best theory of physics and
yet we don't understand it there are
other things we also don't understand
for example we don't understand how
gravity fits into the quantum mechanical
paradigm and no one seems to have I had
the idea that maybe the fact that we
don't understand quantum gravity is
related to the fact that we don't
understand quantum mechanics itself so I
think that understanding quantum
mechanics itself will be really really
helpful in our pursuit of a theory of
everything of once and for all final
theory of the way the world works at a
much more down-to-earth level technology
is improving to the point where quantum
mechanical effects are becoming manifest
in the devices that we build we're
building not only quantum computers but
quantum cryptography quantum
eavesdropping a whole bunch of
applications of quantum mechanics and so
we're going to be needing to know what
the rules are of the quantum world we're
gonna need to do better than the kind of
slapdash recipe we put together in the
1920s can you talk a little bit about
what the many worlds theory is well when
you make a measurement of a quantum
system the system can be in what is
called a superposition it's neither here
nor there it's in the superposition of
every possible place it could be but
when we look at it we never see a
superposition we see every single
possible measurement outcome but only
one at a time and so what many-worlds
says is what you're missing the trick is
to realize that you yourself are a
quantum mechanical system that means
that you can be in super positions so
when you measure a particle and it could
have many different possible locations
it's not according to many worlds that
once you observe it it collapses to a
single location rather the particle is
still in many possible locations but you
are in many possible measurement
outcomes there's a world where the
particle was there and you saw it there
there's another world where the particle
is over here and you saw it over here
and this is a straightforward prediction
of the equations of quantum mechanics it
sort of been lurking in implicitly in
the formalism since the Schrodinger
equation came along in the 1920s and we
just need to face up to that reality now
is this for
people who are hearing and saying that
is this a multiverse sort of theory the
idea that I'm married to person a in the
world in which you know you and I are
currently speaking but there's another
world in which I'm not married there's a
third world in which I'm a tiger I mean
you know however far you want to take it
and sort of cartoonish is it concurrent
with that idea or is it actually
something a little different it is a
version of that idea absolutely but it's
not just that there is every possible
universe there are certain universes the
ones that arise because of how the laws
of physics play out and there are not
other universes but there's a huge
challenge that is raised by many worlds
because there's the notion of personal
identity that we have I mean in the
sentence you just said you said is there
a world in which I am a tiger okay so no
there's no world in which you are a
tiger there might be another world in
which other things happen that created a
tiger out of the same descendants that
you had right or there's another world
in which there's a version very similar
to you in which you had something
different for dinner last night or
married a different person or something
like that but they're not you these
people in the other worlds are all
separate every person in a world is an
individual and all the individuals are
different people so I think sometimes
when people think about the multiverse
theories they share an identity with
that quote other version of themselves
that is in some of these other universes
that seems as I hear you saying it may
be a slightly overly simplistic way of
thinking about it yeah I think that you
know the way the philosophers would say
it is we need to update our metaphysics
in order to take into account how many
worlds works if I'm gonna measure the
spin of an electron and I picked that
because there's only two possible
outcomes it's spinning counterclockwise
or it's spinning clockwise right so then
there will be two people afterward one
person saw it's been clockwise the other
saw it's been counterclockwise and it's
very very tempting for us to say before
we do the measurement I wonder which one
I'm going to be but the correct answer
is there's no answer to that question
there is no one that you're going to be
you are now one person you will have two
descendants a few moments from now they
be separate people they'll be related to
you in the same way that an ordinary
older version of yourself is related to
the younger version of yourself it's
just that there are multiple copies of
them it's a different but completely
sensible way of thinking about reality
so along these lines I want to talk
about entropy a little bit one analogy
that I have found useful in talking
about entropy is to explain and I'm
curious your feedback on this as a
science educator the idea that if you
build a house and leave it there and
leave it subject to weather and
everything else that is going on around
it there could be a hurricane that will
knock some pieces off of it and it might
snow a lot and that would damage pieces
of the roof which would fall off and
eventually the house would basically be
rubble you are not going to then have
those same or other forces happen to get
the house back into the built condition
in which it started is that a useful
analogy to think about entropy yeah no
that's an that's not just an analogy
that's an example of entropy in action
there you go and so when we think about
that as a concept more broadly not
applied to a house but apply to our
universe what are the sort of important
aspects of how and why it matters well
that nothing matters more to reality
into life and to our existence here on
earth than the fact that the entropy the
disorderliness of the universe was very
very low near the Big Bang fourteen
billion years ago and has been rising
ever since the fact that we're all born
young and we grow older with time we age
that's ultimately because entropy is
increasing the fact that you remember
the past and you don't remember the
future that's ultimately because entropy
is increasing the fact that you can make
a choice right now that will affect what
happens in the future but you cannot
make a choice right now that affected
what did happen in the past all is
because entropy is increasing so that
may seem significant sort of to the
individual life but why is that so
significant when we think about the past
and future of the universe well we think
we're not absolutely sure about this but
we think that the fundamental laws of
physics don't actually distinguish
between the past and future if you look
at Newton's laws that we sometimes learn
in our physics courses or if you look at
the Schrodinger equation of quantum
mechanics or Einstein's equation of
general relativity none of them have a
preference for one direction of time
over the other they treat them equally
but the real world seems to have a very
strong preference and we think that the
origin of that strong preference in the
real world is because entropy was low so
if it wasn't for that difference if it
wasn't for the fact that entropy used to
be low we would treat the past and
future on completely equal grounds we
would not remember the past any more
than we currently remember the future
absolutely fascinating as Sean what who
should read the forthcoming book
something deeply hidden and and what in
addition to some of the things we've
touched on will be it will be part of
that book yeah it's for everyone you
know does not assume that you know any
physics it does assume that you're
willing to stretch your mind a little
bit right these ideas are you know it's
not heavily mathematical there's no
equations in the book but they're very
very different from our everyday lives
so it asks not expertise of the reader
but patience and imagination and a
willingness to sort of sit back and
really really think about the
fundamental nature of reality and I'll
talk about quantum mechanics about many
worlds and then at the end of the book I
talk about quantum gravity and how
space-time itself might emerge from a
quantum mechanical wave function of the
universe the book is out in September it
is by Sean Carroll it is called
something deeply hidden Sean so great to
talk to you again appreciate you making
time to talk to me thank you very much
David